the biggest challenge all countries face
right now is striking the right balance
between easing the economy back towards
something near normal
while not risking getting so many people
congregating together that the virus
takes hold all over a game it raises the
question how fast is too fast as summer
approaches especially in places where
infection rates are low some are already
ignoring physical distancing guidelines
and not wearing masks and businesses
can't stay closed indefinitely the
economic impact is massive more than 40
million Americans have filed jobless
claims it hasn't been that bad since the
Great Depression
in Canada it's estimated over 40 billion
dollars has been paid out to Canadians
who applied for the Canada emergency
response benefit and the virus is not
vanished we still don't have any weapon
against it if we reopen too fast there's
a risk it's a matter of life and death
and prosperity or poverty to explore
this I'm joined by dr. Peter singer he
is special advisor to the
director-general of the World Health
Organization and he happens to be
Canadian dr. singer is in Geneva dr.
singer thanks for taking the time the
World Health Organization is constant in
its messaging that were not near the end
of this pandemic in fact we're still at
the beginning as restrictions begin to
be ease what is your greatest concern
well the greatest concern is that the
virus resurgence and so their
restrictions have to be eased slowly
carefully in a stepwise way and that's
actually the way to deal with that with
that fear the modern world of course has
never been through anything like this
as you watch countries tackle this
taking different approaches to reopening
are there basic guidelines on best
practice yes there are and the key the
real heart of the guideline and the
guideline that's put out by the World
Health Organization is to break the
chain of transmission to find the virus
to find the cases isolate the cases
trace
the contacts quarantine the contacts
from a Canadian perspective you might
say put the virus in the penalty box
that is at the heart of guidelines on
easing restrictions well you know South
Korea's uses the example of doing that
the contact tracing the the testing the
quarantine and they kept Kovac 19 from
spreading better than a lot of other
countries but now there's a spike in
cases there as well and South Korea is
shutting down public spaces bars clubs
and sporting venues are being advised to
close what does that tell you tells me
that there's no perfect formula no
country has the perfect formula even the
best countries the best practices here
run into setbacks and then need to
recalibrate that and we see that not
just in South Korea but actually in
every country that's doing well and that
says that the trick here is to go slow
and steady slow and steady wins the race
and also it's very important for
countries to learn from each other
because they all follow it slightly
different paths and it will be important
I think for not just Canada as a whole
but different parts of Canada to learn
from different countries and and parts
of other countries because it's a very
variable situation and that cross
learning is really critical let me ask
you about the antibody tests you know
there was a lot of hope that they would
be used to show who can safely go back
to work now there's evidence of course
that they're not that reliable what's
the latest advice from the wh o on
antibody tests there's many of those on
the market WH o doesn't feel we're at
the point where there's enough validity
testing enough data really behind any of
them to rely upon them certainly not for
clinical decisions even though in the
context of research they are used for
example to see in a hard-hit community
what proportion of people have
antibodies and that number by the way
Donna is disturbing because on average
let's say it's 10 percent that means 90%
of the people are still vulnerable to
the virus which is why
easing back on lockdowns or watching the
virus spread around the world is so
concerning because most of the world is
still vulnerable to this virus and
that's why there's really no cause for
complacency you know poverty kills too
not as quickly as this virus but having
people out of work leads to financial
hardship and bankruptcy and
psychological distress and domestic
abuse so can the world really afford to
wait until we get a vaccine to fully
reopen the health consequences and the
economic consequences are often pitted
against each other one or the other
that's not really maybe the best way to
characterize it because the economic
consequences flow from the health
consequences you know there's trillions
of dollars that have been lost here but
at the heart of that is the public
health problem it is the virus is the
best way to solve the economic crisis is
to solve the public health crisis do you
think it's likely that we are going to
have to keep living physically distant
lives for a long long time you know I
think that the idea of a magic bullet
that one day will snap our fingers and
this will all be gone in an instant I
think we really have to take a reality
check on that idea a vaccine certainly
could help highly effective therapies
could help but we're still for the
foreseeable future for the months ahead
going to have to live with this virus
going to have to accommodate to it and
hopefully one day soon there will be a
vaccine